it's a boy's weekend then why isn't
Shana going do you hear yourself
do you well since they get to do saying
fun why can't we Oh Chuckie Cheese that
place is a nightmare something that
could be fun is the museum though let
him finish
we already heard Museum it's not gonna
go better
the Museum of the American Railroad oh
yeah that's worse so you see how would
you feel if there were some we're just
like Chuckie Cheese but instead of pizza
and buffets
there's locomotives and placards
explaining their history that's just the
museum I didn't think she'd see through
that how about the planetarium that's
like a movie where you can see real
stars instead of I don't know Gene Kelly
we're never gonna agree let's just do
rock paper scissors no anecdotal
evidence suggests the players familiar
with each other will tie 75 percent of
the time due to the limited number of
outcomes well what if we added a few
more choices like rock paper scissors
candy puh me now you're just being silly
but your idea of a winner-takes-all
competition is a good one
we just need to come up with something
that is fair to both of us what if we
list all the spices in mom spice rack
alphabetically I'll go first
adobo black pepper cinnamon coriander
cumin we're not playing the spice game
nice you decided to stay home and play a
game nope we're inventing a new game and
the winner gets a pickle we do today we
had to find a way to make sure that it's
completely fair to both of us so we made
a list of 20 challenges that combine
stuff we're both good at everyone's eats
challenge cuz take a block and put on
top of our Tower
whoever's tower reaches the height of
this rocket first wins okay I will leave
you to it and finally both parties agree
the loser will do the activity selected
by the winner graciously without
complaint
for the purpose of this agreement of
complaint is defined as any disparaging
comment on roles or name-calling
including but not limited to dingus fart
breath and butt wipe
we just sign and play I've signed my
name
feel free to draw an X I know how to
write my name shoulder Sheldon
there are alternates naming a state wall
hula-hooping the first player who can't
name a state or drops the whole loop
loses ready set go
that's it dormant so I won yes good
because I was just gonna say Texas again
[Music]
one two three
[Music]
I win
you can't set it that way does it say
that on the rules well no and is this
your signature yes
but mom are going to Chuck E Cheese
we're not going anywhere it's almost
your bedtime sorry hon
while all that matters that I'm the
winner yes you are actually I was the
winner we spent the whole day doing
everything I love drafting contracts
arguing about rules and most importantly
never leaving the house
come on I don't want to is one more time
fine rock scissors candy Pony Rock trips
pony
I went how do you keep running you keep
picking pony
[Music]